so hello everybody i am here with mario
bagus
mario is a scholar in sydney he uh
teaches at san andreas greek theological
college
um he is he sent me a book which in
which he wrote about
the symbolism of the foundation of
constantinople but also based on ancient
uh civilizations as well i found it very
interesting
his understanding constantinople and
kind of its its place in world history
and uh and mythical history which you
you uh if you watch my
last conversation with richard rowland
you will see that we're kind of going in
that direction
so i was hoping to talk to uh mario a
little bit
and uh and explore the kind of the
foundation of constantinople's place
in how the ancients viewed the world and
kind of its mythical
position let's say so mario tell us a
little bit about
your own background you know how you
kind of came to the subject
and uh and tell me tell us a little bit
about the impetus for your book
uh jonathan i do like you for having me
on it's a real
uh blessing and a privilege um you're
much loved
here in sydney especially in the milieus
that i that i'm moving so
when i mentioned to some faculty and
students uh
that i would be speaking with you um the
responses were oh the symbolism guy and
also oh he spoke to jordan peterson i'm
like yeah that's that's him
so it's uh it's a real honor um the
impetus for my
book well it goes back almost a decade
to when it's when i started my phd
um and i i was kind of being geared up
to teach history at the college that you
mentioned where i'm teaching now in the
disciplinaries
and so i was interested in in symbolism
which uh you know more than i do about
symbolism but i was interested in
in looking at how architectural
symbolism
imaged uh a particular civilization's uh
image of the cosmos their view of the
cosmos and
uh you know honing in specifically on an
orthodox christian vision of the cosmos
as well
so how did constantinople reflect an
orthodox christian
vision of the universe and uh that was a
broad topic
um too broad for uh my purposes so we
basically had to
have to look at the founding of
constantinople um
which uh took place in the fourth
century of course in 330 a.d
founded by constantine the great uh the
issue
was that at the time i wasn't really
content with the sort of bricks and
mortar approach that we were taking to
the topic it was like
an analysis of um you know the raw
material
of how the city was constructed and so i
moved over to uh
to sydney university to the department
of religious studies where i was able to
undertake an interdisciplinary approach
that
i took into consideration the role of
religious symbolism in the city
and how these symbols facilita
participation
into into the realities that they
pointed to
um but then i realized that you know
when you're discussing the founding of a
city like constantinople
you have to look at the antecedents
because uh
these antecedents were actively let's
say
uh built upon by constantine
and in fact it was inescapable for him
he had to found a city in such a waste
to um reflect the cosmos
in a way that his predecessors had going
all the way back to rulers
in mesopotamia you know that's that's
kind of how cities were built back then
with a religious structure in the center
whether it was a pagan temple or later a
christian church so
i i kind of i went back to city building
in in
ancient history and uh went all the way
back to ancient samaria where the first
cities emerged
and that's where the kind of book comes
out of because if you look at it
the beginnings of um of city building
that's what i start with in ancient
mesopotamia
and then it goes through ancient egypt
where um things become more emphatic in
terms of the way that the cosmos is
recapitulated
uh within their temple structures
ancient egyptian temples of course
reflecting
the cosmogony of various ancient
egyptian cities their respective
cosmogony so how
their visions of the universe function
how the universe came to be in their
midst
and then i looked at greece and rome
and greece and rome are very relevant
for constantinople because constantine
is going to do things like move the
palladion or palladium from
ancient greece and and put it in the
forum in his city
what does that mean what's the symbolism
behind that you know he's modeling
constantinople as a new rome based on
the old rome
so i had to look at the old rome and see
how that was established
it was founded on seven hills
constantinople was going to be founded
on seven kills later
but then perhaps the most important
aspect is the
uh the christian dimension because
constantine
is uh founding his his city up
upon let's say that ancient kind of
pedigree of city founding and that
involves pagan symbolism but he's also
building churches in the city
he's christianizing the topography of
rome and judea and other places
so that was all very interesting you
know what
how is this transitionary figure saint
constantine the great
managing to to found this city
in a manner that's consistent with
ancient civilizations going all the way
back to ancient mesopotamia
the egyptian connection at least is very
clear because you have obelisks in the
city so
in case that wasn't clear um and uh
you know and then also doing it in such
a ways to incorporate
his uh i think is an undeniable commit
uh commitment to christianity which will
become paradigmatic for this city for
the next
thousand years and will kind of set up
the foundations
for this bastion of orthodox christian
civilization so
uh you get you get that in this book i
guess
to the best of my ability i spent 10 or
more years uh putting it together
um and the kind of
the more specific let's say themes that
i address
if we get into the nitty-gritty of it uh
is
how cities uh in the ancient world so
ancient pagan cities
up to the beginning of byzantine
christendom so that's the span and it's
a big one and
i realize that there are deficiencies in
that but but i did my best to make it
work
how they can be seen as um
axis mundi centers of the world imagine
is mundi or
images of the world and axis mundi and
imago mundi were heuristic concepts put
forward by miraceliada the great
romanian historian of religions in the
20th century
um and also i tried to
to link that to to the way that rulers
represented themselves kings represent
themselves because
all of these cities were being founded
by kings and they
were in making these cities images and
centers of the world
and by image and center of the world
we're including of course the heavenly
dimension the terrestrial and the
subterranean
which is the let's say threefold manner
generally speaking that
that uh reality was conceived of at that
time
how these rulers were imitating their
gods in
shaping the cities in in this particular
way uh because
somehow uh at least in uh mesopotamia
but also in egypt
the city embodies the cosmogony yeah
the creation of the world and i think
for a lot of people
some people who are watching this will
think okay this is a pagan thing
this is not uh you know this is just a
pagan thing that entered into
christianity but we have to remember
that
first of all the temple and jerusalem in
the old testament had a
had an exact same approach to reality
the the the
when moses goes up the mountain and
receives the plan of the tabernacle
he's receiving a cosmic image and then
that cosmic image which is
you know the garden of eden and and how
the world lays itself out
then becomes the way in which jerusalem
is built
and find its final reflection in the la
in the heavenly jerusalem
which ends up being kind of a final
cosmic image
of the city as cosmogony and
you know with with everything there even
the idea that the
the outsider the ocean itself is dried
up in the sense that it's as if the
temple or the
this ordered cosmos fills up the
entirety of every possibility and so
it's not
just a pagan thing it's very much a
christian a christian
jewish and christian reality as well 100
100 i address that in the book as well
we look at israel and
and uh and how the temple becomes a
recapitulation of
of precisely that eden of eden and this
feeds into the whole christian narrative
and uh constantine you know i mean he's
uh undeniably a christian undeniably in
his
founding of the city in this way what is
he doing with this sort of pagan
symbolism that is
utilizing this trying to communicate an
underlying message of the city as a
cosmic center
and that becomes replaced by
emphatically christian imagery as time
goes on
exemplified in images like christ van
der kradt or the master of all
in the center of domes but even that and
that's guided providentially i believe
has its anticipants in how cities are
first founded so
it's all kind of yeah so tell us a
little bit about
let's say in the founding of the city
what are some of the
uh let's say decisions that constantine
makes
in order to to create this this cosmic
this cosmic city well i mean
constantine the great is one of those
characters where
you know depending on how you arrange
and look at the sources you end up with
a different representation of constant
time
so i'm committed to the church's vision
of constantine you know saint
constantine the great and
um i think that
when we look at constantine we can trust
tradition to a large extent
but if we're looking at some of the
primary sources that address the
founding of the city
of constantinople we're looking at
figures like eusebius of caesarea of
course
socrates of constantinople who's
continuing
you see this is the first church
historian con socrates is continuing
eusebius's history over a century after
you see this
completed in the 450s so if
constantine's reign is
let's say from uh as
as emperor of byzantium
i mean 300 to 337 let's say
um he found constantinople in 330
uh as emperor of rome sorry 300 to 337
eusebius is a contemporary so he's
writing around uh
constantine's time and later we're
looking at socrates over a hundred years
after that into the 450s
we've got southern epithelia and we've
got phyllis storgis as well who's
an aryan historian so all of these
figures write about the founding of
constantinople
and they all agree whether the orthodox
sources like
socrates and sosa men uh there's
semi-aryan ones like
eusebius or the emphatically aryan ones
like philosophers
that the city was founded according to
god's providence
um eusebius is not really
keen to talk about constantinople much
he's more of a fan of the old rome so
all he says about it
is that he says in the life of
constantine that
the emperor consecrated the city to the
martyr's god
and that is indeed true the city was
founded on the feast day of saint
matthias
who is a martyr of the city of byzantium
which is the old name
constantinople the name of the old city
he was a martyr of byzantium under
diocletian
constantine's uh predecessor and the
initiator of the great persecution
against the christians
so that's all he says then um you have
the next chronologically speaking is to
the storages
and he speaks about the providential
founding of the city
thusly he says that constantine began
his construction on the city at the
place where the porphyry column stands
and that paul free column was in the
center of his forum in the city
um and it was destroyed by a statue of
the god apollo made to resemble
constantine uh it also had christian
relics embedded in its base including a
flask containing the uh
the nerve from the uh uh that it was
anointed the feet of christ
some of the loaves that the lord had
multiplied and so on and so forth
also parts of the true cross discovered
by uh saint constance mother saint helen
were embedded embedded in this this
column so he says that constantine
started there
and that um he was with his retinue and
they were marking out the boundaries for
the city
and he was walking ahead of his retinue
with a spear in his hand
almost like an august liturus you know
uh kind of designating the sacred
boundaries of the city
and he's walking and he's walking
they're all getting tired so
someone who had uh let's say who was in
a position to speak to him freely is
what nostalgia says so somebody in the
in a
in a circle right runs up to him and
says how much father lord and he goes
on until the one who is in front of me
stops so he was following an angel
mocking at the boundaries of the city
and then when um
the apparition vanished he put the spear
in the ground he said
this far and that was uh the point at
which the gate of constantine
in his land walls was built of course
constantinople is a promontory so it's
surrounded by three bodies of water
with land wood walls on the western side
uh
so that's what phyllis storcher says he
also calls it a new jerusalem
which is an emphatic motif it comes back
later on in
uh saints lives in the life of saint
daniel the starlight
saint daniel is on his way to the holy
land and he encounters an angelic figure
it's a monk who's later revealed to be
an angelic
figure who informs him that uh why
why do you go all the way there um there
are robbers on the roads these days and
it's not safe
if you go to constantinople you will
find a sec in jerusalem so this is a
motif that you can see
must be kind of accruing to the city by
the mid 400s early 400s when
philosophies is writing because of the
construction of churches
incorporation of saints relics and so on
and so forth
uh socrates and sozomen they also
discuss
the founding of the city they speak
about
well some of the practicalities some of
the
great fountains that constantine has
built in the city uh
the um the racing circuit the very
famous hippodrome
and some of the spolia that will go into
the hippodrome like the tripods from
delphi
um and all of this has underlying
symbolism about what constantine wants
to communicate about his new capital
the tripods from delta the fact that
he's put a senate in his city to match
the senate of the old rome and so on and
so forth
that we're dealing with and that's
generally what they say about the
founding of the city that it's a
providential
let's say fact yeah and one of the
things people need to
remember or notice is that you know in a
way constantinople is the first
christian city that was founded you know
in the in the conversion of rome and so
despite some ambiguous symbolism as you
mentioned the fact that he has
himself displayed you know portrayed as
the god apollo so there is a
a transition period there is a kind of
strange moment where
i'm sure it's also that constantine
himself is figuring out what this means
you know he he has this kind of
conversion moment or his conversion
movement but he maybe doesn't completely
understand all the implications of what
of what this conversion is but
nonetheless you see him
founding what turns out to be the first
christian city
and what will end up being let's say
the the glory of christendom for a
thousand years that is
the image of the city even in the west
um
of the of the holy city will be
will be this vision of constantinople
you know uh and also the refounding of
jerusalem by saint helen as well
those kind of two acts at the same time
seem to be this this
this marker of this new beginning or
this this new kind of christian
civilization
that's right that's right and he's doing
something similar as well in ancient
uh in the ancient rome the old rome i
mean
it's both providential and also a mark
of
incredible let's say shrewdness that
saint constantine
built materia or churches shrines
above the tombs of the martyrs who were
because of the prescriptions regarding
performing executions within the city
itself and the fact that cemeteries were
outside of the city
um in the various necropolis outside of
rome
and that he built these material in a
circle
and i won't take credit for this it was
once remarked to me by professor
um is his name that it's like
because i had i discussed it you know
he's built say agnes saint sebastian
saint lawrence saint paul outside the
walls uh saint peter's on the vatican
hill
he's ringed rome in churches and he's
built maybe one or two within rome
itself
not many within the city but that's
that's fine
and so it's like a new sacred boundary
for rome where if you're coming into
rome
through one of its main let's say
arterial roads you know all roads lead
to rome after all
um you encounter you'll encounter one of
these basilicas because that's what he
would have been building
these rectangular sort of churches the
first very first monumental christian
architecture
um so i mean we have a lot to be
grateful for in relation to
constantine's reign but
could you imagine a conversation between
uh you know um
uh i don't know i've always thought of
it like a
couple of uh pagan soldiers riding into
the city what's that new building
and what's that image on top of it you
know oh yeah that's uh what the
christians believe in that you know
and uh if they inquire further they'll
discover the name of the saint that it's
dedicated to and the saints
the narrative of the saints life and so
it's an incredible testimony in witness
that takes place in rome in the holy
land as you said on the places of
christ's crucifixion and resurrection
and his birth
and also in constantinoples in
constantinople it's towards the end of
his reign so
what we're seeing there is the
beginnings of christianization that he
didn't really get to
to um to its let's say
zenith the zenith is justinia it's yeah
a couple of years later right
but he started it off he built holy
apostles in constantinople which was the
mausoleum church where all future
emperors would be
interred again refurbished by justinian
because saint justinian
he basically rebuilt all of
constantine's edifices in the city
um so holy apostles and uh
at least uh holy peace
were built by constantine he began work
on holy wisdom
very certain but it wasn't completed
until the reign of his son
and he built new churches outside the
city so you know all of these seasons
how many things can you do
in one lifetime as well
or something like that for one statue
that looks like apollo i mean come on
that
you know it's ridiculous but yeah he did
a lot
and the image that you had i wonder
there may
not be any sources of that but the image
of that you uh described of constantine
carrying
the slants out you know and planting it
in the ground
really brings up that image of
constantine's lance which found which
supposedly found itself you know in in
western europe in the hands of
king otto and how it became kind of this
image of the holy lands
you know there because that that land
supposedly that king otto had was
constantine's lands and had supposedly
relics of the
of like the nails of of of christ which
were embedded inside this
this slant and so you know and just like
when you said that image i just had this
vision of
of this relic that we've seen you know
this kind of uh this holy land that
we've seen uh
in all kinds of all kinds of fictional
stories as well
yes spear of destiny and all that kind
of stuff yeah yeah exactly well
supposedly that's where that's the
origin of it king otto had gotten it
from
it had belonged to constantine in the
past and so like this whole and then it
goes into germany and then it has
a whole history uh in germany as well so
it's like
one of the things i want to bring up i
guess the reason why i'm i'm talking
about that is
just how different events were that
the way that we think of it like the way
that we think of founding a city
we don't think of augers we don't think
of you know
taking a lance out and following an
angel in order to plant
the land but this is really how ancients
uh understood reality and this is really
also i mean not just even before
christian times you know there really
was this sense
of the of using augers and using a
spiritual intuition in order to act it
wasn't just
this kind of cold cynical uh political
action there was something
there was something underlying it let's
say there was a vision underlying what
they were doing
and that's what also let's say created
the stability of the city for so long
you know we we moderns we are so smart
but we haven't yet made anything that's
going to last a thousand years you know
we
we we let's see how history treats us
you know
it's not that simple i agree with you
100
and look i mean there's something about
this um
cosmos chaos dialectic that was really
uh directly experienced by ancient and
medieval persons that translated itself
into this sort of
city building and need to to cosmos size
of the space
to bring heaven down to earth in the
space to respond to
manifestations of the sacred in such a
way that you dwelt near them
well these are the things that people
like eliade addressed in relation to uh
religion uh die chronically or religions
die chronically but
it can also be seen in relation to uh
to christianity to orthodox christianity
now we build our churches upon the
places where the martyrs are killed if
we can
we incorporate sacred relics into our
churches
um eliader spoke about higher off in
these manifestations of the sacred in a
very vague and general sense but
we can speak about theophanies which
we've seen the old testament you know
the disclosure
of the trinitarian god to prophets in
the old testament to um
to uh to saints throughout the history
of the church and we honor that by
wanting to dwell near that or to kind of
you know be as close to it as possible
to honor the spot to adorn it to
recreate the circumstances in which that
initial
theophany took place so that we can
partake of its blessing
you know this is something that
absolutely conditioned cities
in ancient times and in medieval times
the modern city
uh tried to incorporate sunglasses i
think with neoclassicism
and everything else but ultimately as
lewis mumford a great historian of
cities uh said the fate of the modern
city was to become a backdrop for
advertising because
you know our contemporary discourse is
all about economy
um now instead of temples or or churches
in the centers of
cities uh what we have are central
business districts
and that yeah times square is the holy
place of uh
you know of new york a hundred percent
and you know
ironically in times square i mean i i
happened to to visit the us in 2013 and
there's that um statue of honoring a
catholic priest i think it is with the
celtic cross behind him
and i thought of the symbolism of that
you know it's entirely dwarfed by
coca-cola
signs and you know all of that other
stuff which
on an existential level as well as
problematic what's good about
constantinople in medieval cities
is the iconography and you're the expert
on this uh the saints giving the
blessing of peace
are engendering this passion and
constantinople was full of images like
this not only in churches but in the
public space
in the thoroughfares all medieval cities
were
all medieval christian cities were but
especially constantinople was the
paragon
um but today the opposite takes place in
fact
um because of the the need to market
products to us our passions are
exacerbated you know it's
they associate the product with the
semi-naked person or something like that
it's very different it's not um we've
lost that wisdom jonathan i think
yeah indeed um and so i
maybe you can tell us a little bit about
because one of the problems of
our historical perception is that the
west has almost completely effaced the
memory
of constantinople and this is of course
a
a strange delusion that has come about
and
i sometimes struggle to see where it
started um
but definitely by the time we reach the
modern age most people don't understand
how important constantinople was how how
important it was in terms of meaning
you know not just in terms of commerce
which it was not just in terms of
politics which it was
but also as this vision of a of a holy
city of
of a christian city um and so you were
telling me a little bit offline
uh about some of the some of the
perceptions that you had
of how important constantinople was in
the middle in the middle ages and maybe
you can
expound on that a little bit for us well
i mean you have the historical uh let's
say
uh impressions that we get out of the
emissary sent by the kievan rush
to constantinople when they reported
back to prince vladimir they said uh
something like after they had entered a
year sophia
and experienced the holy liturgy we knew
not whether we were in heaven or on
earth
i mean uh it was really considered
to be um some kind of a mystical place
constantinople could be said to be
mystical um
for several uh reasons
the grandeur of its buildings i mean and
this links back to what you said about
the west not taking constantinople
seriously
obviously in the discourse uh in in
western academia
at least since the 1700s with the
enlightenment there's
um this let's say trajectory whereby
you know uh tradition religion all of
these sorts of things have to be either
ignored or mocked when it comes to
studying them in their past and their
past manifestations so
this is part of the reason why
historians like um
let's say edward gibbon and before him
the french thinkers voltaire and others
ignored byzantium mocked it decried it
all these sorts of things
and so that affected the scholarship
because
when people were going back and studying
past civilizations it was all about the
glory of ancient greece and rome but
then they didn't
want to acknowledge that rome continued
in the east
and with the continuation of rome in the
east what you also have
is the continuation of engineering
practices
you have the continuation of artisans
and their trades
you have the uh scholarship
historiography
uh playwriting all these sorts of
philosophy
and all of that feed it fed into
constantinople there's a map at the back
of warren tread gold's
the early byzantine historians i believe
the book is called
which shows all of these
it's all it's all the sources that we
basically have about
the uh byzantine period
articulographical sources
uh where these people were born these
great historians and thinkers
and where they all ended up in
constantinople it's all these
kind of lines heading towards
constantinople right so
it was the place to go um in justinian's
time
the kind of let's say monumental
architecture was unsurpassed
a year sophia was the largest building
in the world at the time after he had
finished construction in 332 a.d
you know he had said something like
solomon i have surpassed thee
it's bigger than the temple in jerusalem
right so uh he built maybe 50 churches
in the city
50 churches in the city justinian to
accommodate the population so
we have that practical monumental
christian
architecture all of which is reflecting
the christian vision of the cosmos
cruciform churches to participate
in christ's death on the cross the
beginnings of
domed structures in the fourth century
are perfected by justinian with
his dome in aya sophia by the time you
get to the 9th century
in spite of the islamic incursions in
places like
palestine and egypt and syria
constantinople is still the jewel of the
world
uh the muslims want to capture it
because they know that it's full of
treasures and riches and bounty and
everything else
the west wants to kind of well you know
it's at least in those centuries it's
kind of like charlemagne's trying to
marry empress irene
yeah yeah yeah somehow you know it's
like we want to be part of this somehow
it's it's the envy of the world we also
despise they despise
the byzantines too it was this back and
forth um
eventually what you have in 1204 is the
fourth crusade which sacked the city in
and leveled it but all of these
testimonies speak about a place which
was unparalleled in terms of
art architecture and spirituality if you
read
constantine por philo yenitos book of
ceremonies
uh this this book describes uh all of
the um
the public services and rituals
that the emperor had to participate in
and there were many i think there were
17 that he had to be part of
and it describes them in detail and it's
almost like if you have this this
concrete space
which is reflecting heaven on earth and
in the public space you have images of
christ in his saints
um the ban here the mother of god
everywhere everywhere right
and the actualization of that symbolism
with the rituals and the processions and
the
and the public worship you know it's it
almost like seems like something out of
a dream
and i think that part of the reason why
this city
inevitably fell a thousand years later
because you know it bounced back after
the fourth crusade
it also kind of um in those last
centuries uh
was able to do things in terms of
spiritual achievements
that are un they have no parallel i
believe because you have the
the most let's say uh deft refinements
in hezekiah sarcastic practice in those
last centuries so
that's spirituality you have uh and
you're the expert again here
the best iconography project yeah yeah
you reach the the apex you know that
so many people recognize of iconography
happens you know at the twilight of its
political power why is all of this
happening i mean
it has to do with a certain mentality a
certain disposition
of course that mentality and disposition
has been facilitated
by centuries of church building and uh
public processions and veneration of
relics and
and the commissioning of art and all
these sorts of things theological
controversies theological debates
iconoclasm the victory and triumph of
iconoclasm
and then you reach the end of this
civilization and
you know you get stories like oh yeah
the emperor andronicus paleologos
was in a senate meeting and saint
gregory balamassa's father was ecstatic
so they didn't want to bother him
exactly it's like it's it's still yeah
like you said it's it
the the holiness and the the uh the
admiration of the saints and this kind
of possibility of
of just saying that it's like oh he was
in an ecstatic state so we
we didn't want to bother him well
i mean we have that from the sources and
i don't remember which one but it tells
you a lot it tells you that both the
saints
you know was in that moment speaking
directly with christ
and it says that the emperor recognized
it and so did the other senators so
something very special is happening it's
why the world
fell in on that city in the end i
believe and
one of the reasons why at least uh was
for the preservation of orthodoxy
because
part of the problem that was always
there for the byzantines i mean
the church within that framework
both responded to challenges that the
imperial court in constantinople kind of
exerted itself against the church
because there's
always that risk that because of all
this material wealth and everything else
that
would lead to pride and that this city
was in fact god's kingdom on earth
it reflected that kingdom it initiated
participation into that kingdom which is
what happens every time we go to liturgy
but it wasn't that kingdom christ's
kingdom is ultimately beyond the world
manifested within the world through his
churches right so
um that hubris was there and
the byzantines were let's say
pedagogically humbled throughout
their long history because of this
hubris um
and what we see at the very apex of the
empire
is the church reaching its destination
let's say
and transmitting to the orthodox church
uh
throughout the next centuries up until
today um the the the treasures of
orthodoxy
the the individual establishments are
finally dissolving um
heroically with yeah the last game bro
constantly in paleologos
he's one of those um we're talking just
before the recording he's one of those
last emperors
uh you know the marble king who will
come back and
and all that kind of stuff you know all
of this stuff has its anticipates in
constantinople all of these myths about
uh great final kings who will um finally
and decisively
uh let's say become victorious over the
enemies of god's people or of a
particular nation and then will transfer
their kingdom to
the king of all kings christ that's all
there in byzantium it goes all the way
back to the apocalypse of
methodius that you mentioned uh before
yeah it's something that we
that we're right now kind of bringing
back to the fore i hope with people and
people kind of
understand that also this
this eschatology and this universal
history which was there in
constantinople and this vision of
of the world one of the things you told
me before uh
was your you met you one of the things
that helped you see how important
constantinople was
was how you found it in scandinavian
writing
yeah and it's just i mean what's it
doing there you know i thought
there's no way that a when was snorri's
jewelers and 13th century uh
scandinavian
uh yal and uh uh chronicler
why would he have anything to do with
troy you know i never thought or
constantinople so he's uh
writing in his prose edda
uh about the uh beginnings of
civilization there's some genesis there
you know creation
um narrative and he's mixed up uh
scandinavian uh
let's say pagan mythology with with
emphatically let's say
biblical motifs and then he ends up
speaking about
uh troy as uh the earliest let's say
city where many of the heroes came from
and then constantinople uh what was the
name of constantinople uh
in scandinavian uh mikkel gard or
something like that well
i i don't remember but
you know i mean that that kind of
shocked me so that the influence of this
city extended all the way up until uh
to scandinavia which is not surprising
given the varangian presence you know
yeah exactly that exchange that would
have been happening between the
between the prince of kiev the
varangians and then the scandinavians
there would be this
this exchange of stories and information
that would be happening uh
amongst them amongst them it's the
medieval world was not as
closed off as people want to to portray
it as at all
absolutely not absolutely not and this
connection with um
with troy is very interesting i'm not
sure if you're interested in exploring
oh yeah definitely this is actually
this is where i was going to go next in
our discussion because one of the the
elements that's important in terms of
understanding constantine is almost like
this mythical
figure is how he leaves britain
which in legendarium was founded by a
descendant of the trojans
you know this the descendants of the
trojans is a roman were also
descendants of the trojans and then goes
all the way with his mother helen
all the way to troy basically i mean
constantinople isn't
basically troy like where it is it's in
anatolia it's it's right where troy
would have
people would have understood troy to
have been a very long time ago
and so it kind of bridges all these
worlds together creates this christian
city
which is the resolution of the whole
trojan ark from the time of troy
into this city which joins both the
christian
and the pagan story together in this
kind of amazing synthesis so
i mean that's kind of how i see it but i
don't know if you have some insight on
that
no i i think i never considered it in
this reflexive manner and that just puts
it all together wonderfully jonathan i
mean
certainly we have and i don't remember
if it's southern or socrates it's one of
those mid 5th century
byzantine historians they say that
constantine considered troy
as the location of the the founding of
the city but was told by god in a dream
not to build a troy
and that also in another scenario
considered one of those cities that made
up the the troad
nexus of cities uh where ajax killed
himself one of the heroes again from the
trojan epic but again the association
with
suicide he didn't want that so he went
into
he went to byzantium so that's picked up
in the historiography of the time
but what constantine does do he he links
constantinople to troy
via the paladio palladium
which according to apollodorus we know
from his library
it was a statue of the goddess palace
uh who died uh in a in a kind of uh
fight with athena
zeus uh apparently uh you know as the
myth goes intervened he imposed his ages
his great shield as the girls
were fighting and athena struck palace
dead and she didn't mean to so being
grieved for her she created a statue of
palace
tied uh zeus's uh shield to it and uh
venerated her but then
zeus uh uh at the time of electric
violation it says in the texas
with the myth concerning electra takes
the palladium and
throws it to earth and it lands
according to this myth
on the place where illus son of triass
will build troy in honor of his father
so it's uh that's that's the myth
concerning the palladium
uh in relation to the greek context that
it lands on detroit
what will become the city of troy and of
course helium is
a name of troy the troas is the dad
ilus is the sun and you can call it
either troy or ilion
it lands on this spot and euless builds
a city around this spot and
scholars have theorized it could have
been a meteorite or something like that
that he built a temple
around it and then so you know hate
scholars so much
sorry what's the point right yeah
exactly my goodness all right sorry
no no no no not at all and so uh yeah
you know
i agree um but uh what happens next is
um
that the uh it becomes associated with
the destiny of troy
uh when the city falls to the to the
greeks
that um odysseus and uh diomedes they
take the palladium
out of the city and that's why it falls
so it's a stabilizing
object and it's taken
by them but by them or by aeneas it
depends on the source to livinium
livinium becomes uh uh
the uh let's say antecedents for
latium latium becomes eventually the
background for rome and rome scandinavia
wait so this
the tradition of aeneas taking the
palladium is that
in is that in the greek sources or is
that in the latin source is that in the
in virgil or is that it was that even
there before
that's in latin sources oh yeah uh i i
don't remember if it's in virgil
virgil but you'll find cicero and others
refer okay
so it's scattered in references
regarding the the description of the
palladium because when it's taken to
rome
it is housed in the temple of the vessel
virgins
where the perennial fire is kept that
symbolized rome's
permanence so it's associated as an
object that was meant to facilitate
stability because it was that
talismanic object in troy it's now
helping to facilitate the stability of
rome
being placed right next to the perennial
fire
um and and the sources uh
again various to what happens next it's
either lost when the temple uh
burns um uh is it the
second century ad i'm not quite 1918 i
think it burns then was it lost then
wasn't it we don't know but it turns up
again at constantine's
forum in constantinople and again the
sources vary procopius says oh he he was
digging
at the spot and there it was um you know
other others say that he moved it there
he probably had one constructed you know
uh purpose built for for the um
uh for the occasion this would have been
this would actually have been like a big
shield is that what
would it look like it's a statue of
athena
so this is what it morphs into
eventually a statue of athena holding a
shield
yeah okay here and you can see it uh
there's there's one in
athens um outside one of the uh
museums in athens you can see like a
modern replica so it's basically a
statue of athena holding a shield
and palace athena uh is one of the
epithet's palace one of the epithets of
athena because after she kills palace
she takes on the name so um
that's at the base of constantine's
forum
uh where that statue of him and the
guise of apollo is
at the very base the column is still
there of course in modern-day istanbul
you can go and see it
uh so it was placed at the base of the
forum um
again stabilizing cosmic imagery not
necessarily for worship
or for veneration it's it's making a
point the point is
constantine if rome was considered the
successor of troy and that was part of
let's say the emperor augustus's
narrative for rome that we have
this ancient pedigree going back to troy
and with the descendants of heroes and
we're better than the greeks basically
that's what augustus was trying
to say constantine is saying well i'm
going to take it
one up a notch and it's constantinople
that is now the successor of both rome
and troy so you have this lineage yeah
and
one of i mean people are struggling with
that symbolism i can understand but
there that type of symbolism continues
on in the church
in this in the let's say the
architecture of the narthex or the
understanding of the north x
or the the place of the secular and the
the understanding of continuity within
the church as
being part of let's say the universality
of the church and so
if we understand christianity this is
something i keep harping on with people
that christianity is ultimately non-dual
in its
proposition that if we understand the
man in which christianity can encompass
all things
then we need to have a hierarchy in how
that happens and the idea of
using for example uh spolia of this idea
of having
of recap of taking even these old
statues of the
greek gods and having them kind of out
in gardens and you know
having them in the forum let's say
rather than in the church
is can be understood also as this
manifestation of this hierarchy of how
everything is kind of contained together
but there is a clear hierarchy
in what it is like you said those
statues weren't there to be venerated
to worship they were there as a reminder
and as a memory of
of how we are still a continuation of
the past
just like in churches uh you know you'll
find often find the greek philosophers
that are represented in
uh in the north x it's a little let's
say it was refined with time like you
would never
in the church today find like an image
of a greek god let's say in the narthex
but the idea of like this kind of
fully containing uh reality where things
are
organized hierarchically seems to be at
least this is
seems to be to me to be what uh
constantine was
kind of aiming for you know he wouldn't
have put his his
column of himself as apollo in a church
he put it out
in the forum which is a very different
space in terms of understanding what its
function is uh
and it connects into the people and to
the history into the past and all that
i agree 100 and look i mean nothing
happens in a vacuum constantine was
founding a new city
and an additional reason why the apollo
imagery was used is that city founding
was tied up with solar worship going all
the way back to mesopotamia
that doesn't make constantine and adept
of the sun god he drops solar imagery
from
all of his mata he's his queens
by the 320s it's all gone but he can't
found a city otherwise
it has to be done according to these
prescriptions it would have
compromised his whole project if he had
not let's say
undertaken this uh this kind of measure
and it has to be seen in relationship to
everything else he's doing
and everything else is doing his pro
church i mean legislation the council's
uh
church building that we discussed so but
you know i mean
there's no reason to be
scandalized by it i don't think and i
i think what we see with constantinople
in in particular and i mentioned it in
the book is uh
the beginnings of a museum-like culture
where these um well you still have
pagans in the city but you have
christians in the city as well
constantine is a christian so
he's bringing over this statuary it's
part of the greco-roman inheritance
the statuary stays until the end of the
empire when it becomes emphatically
orthodox it's looted by the crusaders in
1204 crusaders are ripping down
a elizabeth statue of hercules a bronze
one
and cutting it to pieces which means it
was there the 12th and
900 years and no one had a problem with
it
you know pagan texts were being taught
in the curriculum um
but not for their paganism for their
stories for their artwork you know
these texts were being read in a
christian way they were being
psychologized by even by saints of the
church we know that with
saint basil the great news address to
the youth so you know all of these
things have their place
in a taxonomy in a hierarchy you're 100
correct
they are part of the the inheritance of
this civilization
they can be used pedagogically but
within churches
what you have are images of christ and
his saints and whatever motifs
look similar to pagan motifs within
churches because things were borrowed
their meaning has changed you know it's
like the form might be similar but the
content
is revolutionized in light of the christ
experience it becomes very different
so this is something that in orthodoxy
at least can be traced very easily
because
of this emphatic emphasis
on explicit christian imagery
iconography
within the ecclesial space yeah and it's
interesting because you have two
narratives let's say
there's there's a protestant narrative
which wants to represent
orthodox christianity whether catholic
uh you know or
eastern orthodox as just being a massive
synchro syncretic
effort where they just basically took
the the
roman gods and replaced them with saints
or whatever and they just had all these
roman gods and everything so you have
this one narrative
then you have the other narrative which
is like the the scholarly
uh the kind of weird the more scholarly
narrative which is that
christians destroyed the temples they
burnt down everything they wanted to
destroy the ancient world and kind of
get rid of it so you have these weird
two narratives that kind of coexist
the truth is that it's neither of those
it's and that's why these two can exist
is because it was more of a organic this
kind of organic hierarchy
like we're talking about where the the
ancient world was still there was still
let's say remembered at the level that
it should be remembered appreciated
at the level that it could and then but
then everything was kind of
placed in a hierarchy where we would you
know at the summit would always be
christ and the saints and
you know the body the body of christ and
you know lower down in the gardens and
in the
in the parks we could have these these
old statues that remind us of where
we're from and
you know and it's kind of the old
beauties of the ancient world
that's right and and christ the pandora
is the
uh exemplification of that because he's
the master of
all uh represented in domes that are
meant to symbolize the cosmos
um within most churches in
constantinople throughout the orthodox
world
that is our highest aspiration in
yearning
that is what we believe that christ is
the master of the universe and
his saints participate in that mastery
of the universe by
you know being endowed with his grace by
being able to do what
he does by grace and so on and so forth
and that's why they're represented in
close proximity to him first and
foremost being his holy mother
that's where byzantium uh ends up very
early
constantine sets up the parameters and
they're filled in very quickly
thereafter i mean in the 400s you have
saint bucheria building churches
to the mother of god everywhere by the
450s after the third ecumenical council
you know which
uh debated the issue of uh of the del
dorcos
there are churches dedicated to popping
up everywhere and again understood that
she is the main intercessor to christ
our god uh with every new controversy
new churches pop up
uh giving witness to the christian
worldview that christ is at the center
of it all but that didn't mean that they
couldn't appreciate
you know a piece of literature or the
art from the past
it was literally outside in the
thoroughfares so you'd walk down your
collinated streets and there were your
orators from ancient greece the statues
there were some of your
heroes like hercules and others but once
he got to
the imperial palace you had the hulky
gate and what was on top of the hulky
gate the bronze gate
christ high above everything else
even in the arrangement of the symbolism
you would never have a statue
above a saint you know even in the
public space they would never do that it
was
all kind of spatially arranged in such a
way as to give preeminence to
to what their main meta narrative was
which is the christian one
and to enjoy honor respect whatever the
stories of the past which they also
read for i i presume they're read for
enjoyment the way that we do
and also for uh uh
moral benefit uh even spiritual benefit
they're written from a christian point
of view
no problem with any of that yeah exactly
and one of the things people
always this is also a strange
deformation that has happened
where people have this strange idea that
all the traditional the ancient greek
texts were preserved by the muslims
and that this was the main source of of
traditional texts back
into the west it's like what a weird way
of
of seeing where this is really like the
blind spot of constantinople
you know obviously those most of the
texts all the texts
uh of aristotle that were lost in the in
the uh
in the west you know some of the texts
of plato and then other philosophers
they all came from constantinople that's
where
it's actually when constantinople fell
or during the during the darker times
that the scholars were leaving
the city bringing the texts with them in
order to save them and
that's how they that's most of those
texts that's how they ended up in the
west not
coming from spain where some of them did
come from spain but most of them came
from constantinople
it's the big blind spot as you say it's
the big blind spot and this is something
i hop on about because people are like
you know you still get it again and
again in the academy you know you
christians destroyed culture now we
preserved it from the barbarian hordes
coming from germany and scandinavia
it was preserved by christian monks and
copyists and scribes
this is demonstrable evidences
it's come out in the past century or so
it's no longer just a matter of
conjecture or christian apology it's
fact
you know so uh plato aristotle
thucydides latin texts they were all
there in byzantine and the tragedies
all the tragedies all the the the plays
they were all preserving constantinople
to the point where some of the uh you
know in the middle byzantine period
some authors are doing very strange
things like writing
uh weird uh uh plays
based on these ancient texts like you
get the
pumpkinfication of claudius by seneca
influencing a text in constantinople
called the timarion
in the in the ten hundreds which is like
the strangest text you'll ever read
right about this guy who dies
at the festival of saint um dimitrios in
the
and goes to hell have you heard of this
text no i've never heard of it it's the
most bizarre thing and you're reading it
where would they have gotten because
it's a i mean if there's a syncretistic
text it's this one right you had that
element of vicente
but that element that element was not
the overarching narrative that was on
the level of subculture so
you know people were doing um you know
the
using occult texts and all these sorts
of things but that was always yeah
well the hermetic texts were preserved
in constantinople like
a lot of people it's just weird like
even some modern orthodox
are super like that they're super uh
aggressive against the occult like
i get it you know i get it but they have
this idea that the occult comes from the
west that the cult doesn't come from the
west
those texts came from constantinople oh
jonathan
and then they were translated and that's
what gave you know the
the like 13th 14th uh and then midi uh
renaissance uh occultism came from
constantinople guys
look you're right and i'll tell you what
it's almost as
if the byzantines were sitting on a
powder keg
that when it was transferred to the west
in the renaissance
because that's look i mean the
byzantines
not only do they play a large part in
the renaissance in the west they
basically sparked it it was
people like plethanya mr ethan all of
these
they were neo pagans towards the end of
the empire so before we spoke about the
fact
and again we should emphasize this fact
is that towards the end of the byzantine
empire constantinople was preoccupied
with orthodox spirituality
saw refinements in that spirituality had
more monks and soldiers and more nuns
than married women to produce children
and that's why this
the empire fell but you know all these
people participated in god's kingdom so
you know it's this kind of tragic glory
that's that's mainly what's happening
but you had renegades
uh amongst them and um they were not uh
really they were respected as
intellectuals but they weren't
really uh seen as representative of the
byzantine mentality the orthodox
roman mentality they went to the west
they were hired by the medici
and uh taught in their schools and one
of those figures is uh plethorn
he took his library with him and that's
how all of this strange
renaissance occultism began it's because
that powder keg which the byzantines
knew how to handle
they didn't know how to handle it in
italy in the west at the time
uh yeah but it was that kind of organic
hierarchy that was there
where you know because people have this
idea that christians
you know immediately will just stamp out
anything which is a little odd or little
on the margins
but rather if you have a stable
hierarchy or intellectual hierarchy
then you you're actually able to
tolerate some weird stuff on the edge as
long as it stays on the edge like as
long as that weirdo
doesn't like stand up at the altar and
start reading his weirdo stuff
then it's like okay you do your thing
like just don't don't come and bother
the the the you know the the actual
normal hierarchy of being that we're
participating in
if you want to be on the fringe and do
your fringe thing go ahead but don't
bother us
but like you said when it when it
arrived in the west it's as if there was
already
a revolutionary thing that was set up
there was already a revolutionary
thinking that had been
that had kind of been fomenting and so
it uh it fed it in a different way let's
say
yes i think that's a good way of putting
it and you know i i heard it once from
mark
or i read it somewhere that in relation
to to
witches you know the byzantines had
their their foolish old women that they
just kind of ignored
uh the west had its um devil worshiping
uh
uh which is that it burnt at the stake a
very different approach very different
kind of
but you're 100 uh uh right that the
byzantines
you know unless that person was at
johnny talos or michael
trying to shape the minds of the people
in such a way that was anti-christian
anti-christic would compromise the
salvation of people
then they were kind of tolerated to
exist on the margins
on the on the periphery um
and this is not while discussing this
with you we're not legitimizing these
texts at all
we're just talking about a reality a
reality that points towards the
soberness of
the uh the orthodox christian byzantines
centered in that city
um you know another thing and this goes
back i hope you don't mind i'm jumping
back to our conversation about
um christian and pagan imagery in the
public space
this is something that persists to this
day this
hierarchy and this uh let's say division
between you know
it's in orthodox countries today in
within the churches
icons are venerated outside of the
churches
they will build statues of saints but
you don't see them in the churches
you know and statues of let's say heroic
figures
that are venerated nationalistically
that nations let's say defense of the
faith you see this in russia you see it
in romania
you see it in greece you know you'll get
your statue of constantine biologos
outside of the church but not within the
church within the church
that's where we know that the the god
revealed art form of iconography
is and that we legitimately venerate
yeah that immediately saw space outside
you know they depict all sorts of things
and there's there's an interesting
in russia there's an interesting almost
natural hierarchy which is setting
itself up right now into inter
this renewal of orthodoxy exactly what
you're saying where
we're not going to totally reject the
romantic all of these
uh movements where which you know did
lead towards the end or the
the breakdown of orthodox we're not
going to reject them we're just going to
have them in their place so
in the church like you said we have
these icons but then
the statues we have romantic kind of
neo-realistic statues outside
and it creates this kind of powerful
this more natural hierarchy of being
that that was
probably similar in constantinople well
it's very similar to what was in
constantinople i mean you see it in
greece you see it in russia my wife is
russian so we've been a few times we've
seen it there
it's a byzantine uh thing you know it's
throughout
the balkans romania bulgaria serbia they
do this they
they will kind of keep the good from the
past outside
you know uh there might be military
heroes it might be
you know uh mythical figures but
it's just not in the church the church
is a different space
it's it's the sacred space and that
transition between
the secular and the sacred is made clear
the moment you you enter into the
gnathicks you know which is that liminal
space let's say before you
you go into the nave all right look look
we've been going for a while i'm really
enjoying this conversation
um and so so everybody i will i will
recommend that you check out
mario's book let me put it up so you can
see it um
you can find it on amazon uh you know
it's it's available
and so thank you so much for for your
time i hope this will spark people's
interest and their fascination with uh
constantinople as this mythical
christian city my gratitude to you uh
jonathan christ is recent thank you he
has risen
all right everybody so so thanks for
your attention and i will talk to you
very soon